Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Vous écoutez « 70 minutes avec ». Ça fait un mois que je n'avais plus publié d'épisode et je pense que vous vous doutez de la raison.
J'ai cherché des invités et c'était pas simple. Il fallait non seulement trouver quelqu'un qui puisse être interviewé à distance, mais en plus, il fallait que le sujet soit adapté à la période qu'on connaît actuellement.
Parmi les sujets auxquels j'avais songé, il y avait des choses comme, je sais pas, le harcèlement scolaire, le multilinguisme en Belgique, les enfants soldats, mais à l'heure du coronavirus, tous ces sujets se retrouvaient
tout à coup assez loin de nos préoccupations.
Et en même temps, je n'avais pas trop envie de faire la même émission qui passe à longueur de journée dans les médias où on explique
comment fonctionne le virus, qu'il faut se laver les mains, porter un masque, rester chez soi, qu'on ne sait pas très bien comment la situation va évoluer, qu'on ne sait pas quand il y aura un vaccin.
Je voulais faire un épisode qui soit pertinent par rapport à la situation actuelle. Par exemple, parler de, je sais pas, l'école à distance ou bien pour proposer une analyse de l'impact de cette crise sanitaire sur notre société,
sur la santé mentale des gens, sur la peur, sur tous les autres bouleversements qui résultent de cette crise plutôt que sur le virus lui-même. Et du coup,
j'étais vraiment très content de trouver Olivier Klein, qui est professeur de psychologie sociale à Bruxelles et qui, en plus de devoir donner cours à distance, a justement écrit une série d'articles qui détaillent
exactement ce genre d'analyse.
Et donc, dans cet épisode, on va se servir de la crise actuelle pour passer en revue plusieurs notions de psychologie sociale comme la crédulité, les normes sociales, l'individualisme, etc.
C'est parti. J'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir de recevoir Olivier Klein. Olivier Klein, bonjour.
Bonjour et merci de m'inviter.
Olivier Klein, vous êtes professeur de psychologie sociale à l'Université Libre de Bruxelles et à l'UMONS. Vous êtes vice-doyen de la Faculté de psychologie de l'Université Libre de Bruxelles.
Vous êtes directeur du Centre de recherche en
psychologie sociale et interculturelle et vous vous spécialisez, entre autres choses, en ce qui concerne la mémoire collective, la psychologie du genre, les relations intergroupes et la crédulité.
Est-ce que j'ai oublié quelque chose ?
En fait, comme le montre votre petit résumé, je ne me spécialise en rien. Je suis un peu un touche-à-tout, je m'intéresse à beaucoup de choses.
Oui. Très bien. Et donc, voilà, vous donnez cours en ce moment à l'ULB, vous êtes en charge du cours de psychologie de genre, c'est bien ça ?
Notamment, oui, notamment. Je donne cours de psychologie du genre, interculturelle et du genre avec un collègue.
Et je donne aussi des cours de méthodologie, des cours sur la personnalité, notamment, et des cours de psychologie sociale plus approfondis.
Très bien. Alors, juste pour ceux et celles qui nous écoutent, on avait reçu en fait, il y a à peu près un an dans ce même podcast, Julie Dachez, qui est elle-même docteure en psychologie sociale à l'Université de Nantes.
Et elle s'intéressait à l'autisme à travers, voilà, également la question des études de genre. Est-ce que vous pouvez nous rappeler ce que c'est en fait la psychologie sociale ?
Parce que quand on parle de psychologie, on a en tête le psychologue clinicien qui va nous recevoir sur son divan, nous écouter parler pendant une heure.
Qu'est-ce que c'est la psychologie sociale par rapport à ça ?
La psychologie sociale, c'est une discipline scientifique, en tout cas qui se veut scientifique, et qui s'intéresse à la façon dont la présence d'autrui influence le comportement.
Et cette présence, elle peut être soit réelle, comment on se comporte quand on est avec d'autres personnes, soit imaginée, c'est-à-dire comment mes attentes par rapport à autrui peuvent influencer mes pensées, mon comportement, mes émotions.
Et donc ça, je dirais que c'est vraiment l'objet. Donc par exemple, je sais pas moi, le comportement des foules, mais aussi les stéréotypes sociaux, l'altruisme sont des choses qui vont intéresser les psychologues sociaux.
Mais au-delà de son objet, la psychologie sociale est aussi caractérisée par des méthodes. Et donc,
je dirais que la méthode la plus commune, la plus connue en psychologie sociale, même si c'est certainement pas la seule,
c'est la méthode expérimentale, c'est-à-dire qu'on essaie de créer des situations dans lesquelles on va manipuler une variable, souvent une variable sociale ou liée au contexte social,
pour examiner son influence sur le comportement.
J'ai l'impression que quand on parle de, voilà, de
la discipline qu'est la psychologie, de ce secteur de recherche, on est très pénétré par cette idée que
on étudie l'individu, les particularités de l'individu, chaque personne est différente et que ici, y a davantage l'idée que
on se ressemble quand même pas mal entre individus et que c'est en manipulant notre environnement, les variables sociales, les personnes qui nous entourent et leur comportement que,
on va finalement observer beaucoup de patterns.
Oui, donc les psychologues sociaux, ils adorent
défendre l'idée que finalement, la personnalité ou le caractère sont en fait des choses qui sont purement
contextuelles, qu'en fait les gens peuvent totalement changer de caractère ou de personnalité, en tout cas manifester des traits, des comportements qui correspondent à telle ou telle personnalité en fonction du contexte social.
Alors, c'est une vision très radicale de se dire que la personnalité n'existe pas. Il y a des positions plus modérées, mais je dirais que
de façon générale, la psychologie sociale met vraiment en évidence le rôle de la situation et du contexte social comme déterminant principal du comportement-
Mh, mh
...par opposition à la personnalité, à une personnalité qui préexisterait à cette situation. En fait, pour avoir une vision un peu nuancée, il faut en fait envisager l'interaction entre les deux.
Ça, c'est la position sans doute la plus réaliste.
Et j'allais vous demander votre position personnelle. Est-ce que vous faites partie des
personnes plus radicales qui ont envie d'oublier complètement la personnalité ou bien est-ce que vous défendez une position plus intermédiaire, plus modérée, vous étudiez l'interaction entre les deux ?
Bah c'est une bonne question parce qu'en fait moi quand je fais face à mes étudiants, ils viennent avec cette idée que la personnalité, bah elle existe, c'est une évidence.
Et donc je passe beaucoup de temps un peu à jouer l'avocat du diable, à essayer de déconstruire ça, à montrer même comme l'idée même de personnalité ou d'individu, c'est quelque chose de très récent historiquement.
Mais si je devais articuler ma propre position par rapport à cette question, je dirais qu'en fait y a certaines situations où la personnalité ne joue absolument aucun rôle sur le comportement.
Quand une situation est telle, est très forte et très puissante, finalement, les gens ont tendance à tous se comporter de la même façon.
Si je vous mets un revolver sur la tempe, que vous soyez agressif ou pas, sans doute que vous réagirez plus ou moins de la même façon.
Mais je dirais que dans la plupart des situations beaucoup moins extrêmes auxquelles on fait face, bah il va y avoir ce qu'on appelle des interactions entre la personnalité et la situation, c'est-à-dire que selon la personnalité des gens,
ils vont réagir différemment.
Mais cette personnalité elle-même, elle a été construite, elle s'est élaborée à travers des interactions sociales.
Donc en fait, on a en même temps une construction de la personnalité sur un temps long et une influence sur le comportement qui va
dépendre d'une part de cette personnalité qui a été construite sur un temps long et d'autre part, de facteurs situationnels.
La psychologie sociale, les chercheurs en psychologie sociale, d'une manière générale, défendent l'idée qu'on est très très très très fort le produit de son environnement et-
Une idée très forte, c'est que selon le contexte social dans lequel on se trouve, différentes identités peuvent être importantes pour nous.
Et en fait, on va se comporter en fonction de l'identité qui est importante à un moment donné. Et les comportements qui sont liés à l'une ou l'autre identité ne sont pas nécessairement les mêmes, hein.
Par exemple, j'sais pas moi, l'identité de femme peut être très importante dans un certain contexte et va amener à développer des comportements qu'on considère comme très importants pour une femme, alors que dans d'autres,
une même personne va peut-être plus être--
c'est son identité de professionnel ou son identité de parent qui va être en évidence.
Et donc des comportements très différents peuvent émerger en fonction de l'identité qui est saillante, en fonction de la situation.
Mmh. Alors pour terminer de remettre un petit peu les choses en contexte et présenter, voilà, cette discipline qu'est la psychologie sociale.
Quand on observe la discipline qu'est la psychologie, comme secteur de recherche à travers le monde, et même plus globalement, tout le domaine des sciences humaines,
j'ai le sentiment, de l'extérieur, parce que je ne suis pas, je n'ai jamais étudié les sciences humaines, que c'est assez morcelé.
Est-ce que quand on observe un phénomène
et qu'on a un psychologue social dans la pièce, un psychanalyste dans la pièce, une personne qui va plutôt observer ça à travers un prisme de troubles cognitifs, voilà.
Est-ce que chaque spécialiste en psychologie,
et même on pourrait rajouter peut-être un sociologue dans la pièce, va avoir une façon complètement différente d'interpréter et d'étudier un phénomène et, finalement, ils ne se parlent pas entre eux ?
Est-ce qu'on est un peu là-dedans ou pas du tout ?
Bah alors ça, c'est vraiment une question importante. J'pense que le fait qu'ils ne se parlent pas entre eux, ça peut arriver parce que parfois,
certains collègues ou certains scientifiques vont être tellement attachés à ce qu'ils appellent leur épistémologie, c'est-à-dire la façon d'appréhender leur domaine, que
ils vont rejeter d'autres épistémologies, d'autres façons d'appréhender le domaine.
Et en fait, ces épistémologies, elles font aussi un peu partie de notre identité. Pour vous donner un exemple, je vous disais que la psychologie sociale, elle se définissait notamment par ses méthodes.
On se veut rigoureux en utilisant des expériences contrôlées, etc.
Et donc, a priori, c'est une façon de voir les choses qui ne correspond pas à des approches très qualitatives comme pourrait les utiliser un psychanalyste qui va typiquement
écrire un article sur base d'un cas, par exemple hein, d'entretien avec un cas, avec une seule personne et qui va également expliquer tel ou tel comportement par des conflits
qui dateraient de la naissance, 'fin en tout cas de la petite enfance, etc.
Donc, dans la façon d'appréhender une réalité et dans les méthodes utilisées, il va y avoir des différences très importantes.
Et ça peut facilement mener à des conflits ou à des ruptures de dialogue. Alors moi, j'ai toujours essayé de m'opposer à ça.
J'ai toujours essayé, en tout cas dans mon domaine, de collaborer et de discuter avec des gens qui avaient des orientations très différentes des miennes.
J'ai collaboré déjà avec des sociologues, j'ai eu des relations aussi très professionnelles, très intéressantes avec des psychanalystes.
Donc, je pense qu'il y a moyen de dépasser ces oppositions et de dialoguer si on a une attitude appropriée et qu'on ne se ferme pas totalement.
Mais c'est vrai que ça peut arriver effectivement qu'il y ait des difficultés de communication et des véritables conflits, parce que ces conflits dépassent des questions purement scientifiques.
C'est aussi une question parfois d'accès à des budgets. Pour vous donner un exemple, c'est pas toujours facile aujourd'hui pour des psychanalystes d'avoir accès à des budgets de recherche
parce qu'à peu près tous les autres champs de la psychologie les considèrent comme non scientifiques et pas rigoureux du tout, quoi.
Donc, ça peut créer aussi des problèmes et des difficultés de communication.
Si on revient à la question de la psychologie sociale, qu'est-ce qui vous a amené, vous, personnellement, à vous spécialiser là-dedans ?
Qu'est-ce qui vous a attiré ?
Alors moi, ce qui m'a attiré, 'fin c'est une expérience personnelle et un peu anecdotique. J'ai étudié la psychologie du travail à une époque où y avait pas vraiment
d'orientation psychologie sociale au sens dans lequel je vous l'ai décrite à l'ULB.
Et donc ce qui m'a amené à faire de la psychologie sociale, c'est que j'ai dû faire un travail en psychologie commerciale, si j'ose dire, et j'avais choisi comme thème le marketing humanitaire.
Donc, il fallait faire un travail de marketing. Et donc, je me suis dit : « Pour m'intéresser à ça, je vais m'intéresser au comportement prosocial, à l'altruisme, finalement.
Qu'est-ce qui fait que les gens vont se comporter de façon altruiste ? » en me disant : « Bah si on veut faire du bon marketing humanitaire, il faudrait savoir dans quel cas les gens sont altruistes.
» Et alors, j'ai découvert toutes ces expériences de psychologie sociale sur l'altruisme. Et ce sont des expériences passionnantes où on crée vraiment des mises en scène avec quelqu'un qui a l'air de,
j'sais pas moi, d'être en détresse au milieu de la rue, donc qui est en fait un acteur, et on regarde quelle est la probabilité qu'on aide cette personne en fonction du nombre de gens qui sont présents.
Et donc le résultat le plus frappant là-dedans, c'est que plus y a de gens, plus petite est la probabilité que quelqu'un aide parce que tout le monde se diffuse la responsabilité.
Et donc moi, c'est ce genre d'expérience-là qui m'a vraiment donné envie. Bah voilà, ça, c'est vraiment quelque chose qui m'intéresse.
Et il se trouve qu'à l'époque, l'ULB venait d'engager un nouveau professeur de psychologie sociale, donc qui venait d'arriver, Assaad Azzi.
Et donc, je me suis dit : « Moi, c'est ça qui me plaît. » Et j'ai été le voir, j'ai demandé : « Est-ce que vous seriez d'accord d'éventuellement m'encadrer pour un mémoire ou est-ce que vous avez des...
» Et alors, il a commencé à me donner de la littérature. Et c'est comme ça qu'est née ma passion pour cette discipline.
Avant de se lancer au cœur du sujet, puisque nous allons parler aujourd'hui de la crise sanitaire que nous traversons.
Vous êtes professeur à l'ULB, on le disait. Comment est-ce que ça se passe concrètement, le confinement pour l'enseignement que vous donnez en ce moment ?
Alors, il se trouve que pour le moment, j'ai que deux cours ce quadrimestre, parce que la plupart de mes cours sont en premier quadrimestre.
Donc, j'ai ce fameux cours de psychologie interculturelle et du genre dont je donne la partie genre. Et j'ai un cours aussi à l'UMONS qui s'appelle « Questions approfondies de psychologie sociale ».
Et donc la façon dont se donnent ces deux cours, c'est à distance avec un logiciel qui s'appelle Teams, qui est un truc Microsoft, et qui me permet en fait de donner cours derrière mon micro.
Et eux voient mon PowerPoint, mais ce qui est très chouette, c'est qu'ils peuvent aussi interagir avec moi, donc non seulement vocalement, mais aussi via une petite fenêtre de chat.
Et donc, je peux vraiment interagir à la limite. Donc le cours sur le genre, là, c'est un cours où j'ai un grand auditoire.
J'ai vraiment beaucoup d'étudiants, hein, je pense qu'il y a 400 inscrits. Alors, ils viennent pas tous, hein, au truc Teams, mais j'en ai quand même quelques-uns.
Même confinés à domicile, certains arrivent à brosser les cours.
Ah ouais, bah ouais. Et donc dans ce contexte-là, c'est vraiment,
c'est vraiment intéressant. C'est un nouveau mode d'enseignement pour moi, où finalement, dès qu'il y a quelque chose qui ne va pas ou qu'ils ne comprennent pas, ils le mettent directement dans le chat et donc je peux réagir.
Et c'est beaucoup plus interactif. Je peux par exemple introduire des petits sondages pendant le cours. Donc en fait, je trouve que en termes d'apprentissage pour les étudiants,
c'est assez avantageux parce que comme on détecte immédiatement les problèmes d'incompréhension, les difficultés, on peut tout de suite y répondre.
Alors que si vous parlez dans un grand auditoire, finalement, ceux qui ont de la peine à suivre, souvent, n'osent pas lever le doigt ou exprimer leur incompréhension.
Est-ce qu'à l'issue de ce confinement, vous aurez envie de continuer de cette manière-là ou bien est-ce que vous regrettez malgré tout les cours en auditoire ?
Alors, je regrette bien sûr le fait de ne pas avoir de contact face à face avec les étudiants, c'est quelque chose de très important.
Mais ce que m'a apporté cette expérience, j'aimerais bien l'importer dans des cours en face à face.
Donc, par exemple, si je pouvais incorporer cette possibilité de chat dans des cours en face à face, ce qui est techniquement possible en fait, hein, y aurait moyen de projeter sur l'écran
média et le chat à côté, de telle sorte que je vois les réactions des étudiants.
C'est quelque chose qui, à mon avis, serait vraiment intéressant. Donc ça m'a conduit finalement à m'améliorer en tant qu'enseignant, cette expérience, même si je ne la regretterai sûrement pas.
Euh, OK, donc c'est très intéressant. Et y a aussi la fameuse question des méthodes d'évaluation. Est-ce que vous avez des opinions, des convictions à ce niveau-là ?
Alors, là, je pense que c'est un choix des universités. Donc, la nôtre a fait le choix de ne pas faire
d'examens, d'évaluations avec rassemblement des étudiants dans un même lieu physique, parce que c'est vraiment hyper compliqué à organiser et dangereux, parce que finalement, on va faire aller les étudiants-
C'est plutôt irresponsable, hein, ouais
...oui, on va faire venir les étudiants en transports en commun, puis ne fut-ce que pour rentrer dans l'auditoire, c'est quasiment impossible que les gens ne se rapprochent pas.
Et donc, on le fait à distance. Maintenant, moi, je vous donne l'exemple de ce cours où j'ai 500 étudiants, je peux pas faire des oraux, là.
Je veux dire, c'est pratiquement impossible. C'est assez difficile même de faire des travaux écrits avec un si grand nombre d'étudiants, étant donné la fenêtre temporelle limitée qu'on a pour corriger.
Et donc, là, je vais faire des examens à distance, donc avec ce même, avec les outils que nous propose l'ULB pour faire des tests en ligne.
Et donc la question très intéressante que ça pose, c'est : est-ce que les étudiants vont jouer le jeu ?
Est-ce qu'ils vont le faire sérieusement
ou est-ce qu'ils vont se dire
: « Ah bah écoutez, là, c'est super facile, je peux prendre mes notes avec moi et j'ai qu'à recopier ce qu'il y a dans mes notes ou ouvrir,
ou je peux téléphoner à mon copain pour lui envoyer des SMS pour lui demander quelle est la réponse à telle ou telle question. » Donc,
y a vraiment toute une question dans notre rapport aux étudiants qui est posée ici. Est-ce qu'on voit l'étudiant par défaut comme quelqu'un qui va choisir
la solution du moindre effort et qui se moque totalement du fait que sa note reflète ses compétences ou pas ?
Mmm-hmm.
Ou est-ce qu'on considère l'étudiant comme quelqu'un d'adulte, de responsable qui-- et là, je parle d'étudiants de troisième année hein.
Qui a déjà quelque part un petit peu fait ses preuves en ce qui concerne le sérieux de ses études, ouais.
Oui, et qui finalement n'a pas nécessairement envie de recevoir une note qui ne reflète pas du tout ses compétences, qui est là pour apprendre et qui voit l'évaluation.
Donc entre ces deux extrêmes de l'étudiant parfaitement paresseux et malhonnête et l'étudiant parfaitement vertueux, la vérité est sans doute un peu entre les deux.
Mais moi, j'ai plutôt fait le pari de faire confiance aux étudiants. Donc pour mon examen à Mons, par exemple, je vais leur donner les questions à l'avance et là, je ferai un oral.
Et donc, la question ne sera pas est-ce qu'ils ont accès ou pas à la matière, vu qu'ils auront les questions. Donc ça, je pense que c'est une approche tout à fait intéressante.
Maintenant, il faut savoir que
si on veut faire ça, on doit faire des méthodes d'évaluation très riches, des possibilités de répondre de façon assez élaborée et qu'avec
500 étudiants, c'est logistiquement très très compliqué pour nous, d'autant plus qu'on n'a pas que ça.
Je veux dire, par exemple, là moi, je vais avoir peut-être une trentaine de mémoires et de travaux à lire-
Mmm-hmm
...pendant une période très courte. Donc, on est dans une situation intéressante, aussi bien pour les étudiants qui sont en difficulté que pour les professeurs.
Cette situation est particulièrement tendue et donc on doit trouver un compromis qui puisse fonctionner pour tout le monde.
Alors moi, c'est vrai que pour ce cours de genre, j'ai choisi des choix multiples à distance.
C'est pas la meilleure forme d'évaluation, mais étant donné la situation, je voyais pas très bien comment faire autrement.
Mmm. On va à présent aborder le cœur du sujet pour cet entretien aujourd'hui. Vous avez publié ces derniers mois sur votre blog personnel une série d'articles, une série de billets pour,
observer, analyser le phénomène que nous connaissons tous en ce moment qui est la crise sanitaire du coronavirus.
Parmi les images qui ont très fort marqué ce début de pandémie, on retiendra, entre autres, celles de, voilà, de ces foules hystériques qui s'engouffrent dans les grandes surfaces pour
acheter des caisses de papier toilette et toutes ces images qu'on a pu voir en ligne de tous ces étalages vides.
Comment est-ce qu'on explique ça ? Comment est-ce qu'on étudie ce comportement-là à travers le prisme de la psychologie sociale ?
Alors, avant de vous expliquer mon point de vue, j'aimerais d'abord ici, là-dessus, revenir un peu sur la vision que projetaient souvent les médias là-dessus.
C'était un peu l'idée que les gens, face à l'angoisse de l'épidémie ou de la pandémie, deviendraient un peu totalement irrationnels.
Ils seraient envahis par la peur et cette peur les empêcherait,
de se comporter de façon rationnelle et les amènerait à faire des queues interminables pour obtenir du papier toilette alors que celui-ci serait tout à fait,
en quantité suffisante.
Idem pour les pâtes, etc. Et donc, en fait, cette vision des gens comme totalement irrationnels, surtout quand ils sont en groupe d'ailleurs, c'est une vision qui remonte au 19e siècle et qui, à mon sens, est totalement erronée.
Y a plusieurs recherches qui montrent qu'au contraire, en groupe, souvent, les gens se comportent de façon très coopérative, parfois très rationnelle.
Et en l'occurrence, je pense qu'il y a des explications très différentes qu'on peut faire de ces comportements. Alors, une première qui serait totalement rationnelle, c'est de se dire
que là, on va devoir rester à la maison et que donc on a besoin nécessairement de plus de papier toilette pour sa maison que si on passait la moitié de sa journée au bureau.
Donc déjà, c'est assez logique qu'il y ait une demande plus importante pour du papier toilette dans des supermarchés sans faire appel à la moindre irrationalité.
Par ailleurs, souvent, on sait pas très bien ce qu'on doit faire. Là, ici, la pandémie, pour à peu près tous les Belges, c'était une nouveauté totale.
On n'avait jamais vécu ça précédemment. Et donc, quel comportement utiliser dans une situation d'incertitude ? Ce qu'on fait, c'est qu'on regarde ce que font les autres.
C'est notre meilleur indice. C'est l'indice qu'on utilise le plus souvent en situation d'incertitude, quand on sait pas quoi faire, que font les autres.
Mmm-hmm.
Que nous disent les médias ? Les autres font la file pour acheter du papier toilette.
C'est ce qu'on appelle les fameuses normes sociales, c'est ça ?
Voilà, c'est une norme sociale. Donc, je vais suivre la norme sociale. Et donc, en fait, la norme sociale, c'est : il est légitime et il est pertinent d'avoir peur.
Donc, je vais aller faire la file et je vais avoir peur.
D'accord.
Donc c'est pas nécessairement irrationnel, en tout cas au sens qu'on a pu le décrire, d'aller rechercher-
Ouais
...ces papiers toilette.
On aurait tort de parler de foule hystérique, mais vous préféreriez parler de foule, voilà, sujette aux normes sociales finalement, et inquiète.
On aurait presque tendance à croire en vous écoutant que c'est un comportement parfaitement raisonné, parfaitement sage, parfaitement acceptable.
Mais les comportements auxquels je pense là maintenant, ce sont vraiment les personnes qui,
ramenaient à la maison des colonnes et des colonnes et des caisses de papier toilette, donc un abus total, quelque chose qui était très exagéré et qu'il n'était pas nécessaire de faire.
Alors du coup, si vous expliquez d'où ça vient, je pose ensuite la question : est-ce que c'est quelque chose qu'on serait en capacité de freiner, de diminuer, ces comportements-là ?
Disons que ces comportements-là sont des comportements clairement égoïstes, que je remets pas en cause leur caractère égoïste.
Et donc ce sont des gens qui se disent : « Bah, là, moi, je vais d'abord sauver ma peau » ou peut-être mes fesses en l'occurrence.
Ou celle de la famille, en tout cas, oui.
Oui, c'est ça. Mais le problème qui se pose ici, c'est que la médiatisation du phénomène, finalement, nous communique l'idée que l'égoïsme est la norme.
Quand on montre tous ces rayons vides, alors qu'en fait, y avait plein d'autres rayons qui étaient pleins, mais on va mettre l'accent sur les rayons vides.
Et en fait, on communique l'idée : la norme, c'est l'égoïsme. Et donc, je pense que si on veut faire une intervention par rapport à ça, et je pense que ça a été fait.
Donc, je ne fais pas ici une critique des médias, en tout cas en Belgique, je trouve qu'ils ont fait relativement du bon boulot par rapport à ça.
C'est aussi mettre en évidence la solidarité, montrer que l'égoïsme n'est pas la seule norme, qu'il y a,
qu'il y a plein de gens qui sont solidaires, qui font des sacrifices pour aider les plus en détresse.
Donc je pense que c'est ça la bonne réponse, c'est de communiquer sur les autres normes que le simple égoïsme.
Et alors, je pense que les réseaux sociaux-- alors là, c'est plutôt ma propre expérience, mais je voyais plein d'amis sur Facebook et autres qui, quand ils allaient dans un magasin, prenaient aussi une photo du rayon vide.
Mmh-mmh.
Et bien pour cette raison-là, moi, quand j'ai été dans un magasin et que je voyais du papier toilette, je faisais une photo et j'ai mis une photo sur mon Facebook en disant : « Regardez, là, y a plein de papier toilette, vous inquiétez pas.
» Donc y a vraiment un effet d'entraînement.
Ouais, ouais.
Mais je pense que sur les réseaux sociaux, on voit aussi des actes de solidarité, donc je suis pas sûr que ce soit vraiment lié au type de média.
D'accord, OK. Alors, un autre aspect qu'on pourrait étudier l'espace d'un instant, c'est assez évident que le confinement, la distanciation sont des modes de vie qui sont tout à fait hors norme pour nous qui vivons en société.
Alors, qu'est-ce que vous avez pu remarquer en observant l'instauration de ce confinement chez nous ? Parce que certains craignaient, par exemple, une certaine fatigue psychologique, des frustrations par rapport à ces privations de liberté.
Qu'est-ce que vous avez pu observer par rapport à ce changement de paradigme ?
Oui, c'est intéressant que vous souleviez cette idée de la fatigue, hein. C'était notamment une idée que les conseillers scientifiques de Boris Johnson avaient utilisée pour retarder le confinement.
Ils ont dit : « Les gens vont être fatigués, ils pourront pas résister, donc il faut absolument un peu attendre avant de mettre le confinement en place parce que tout va exploser.
» Et donc peut-être avant de vous répondre sur ce que j'ai observé, je trouve que cette vision des choses, elle rejoint un peu celle de la foule hystérique, hein.
C'est l'idée que les gens, en fait, sont un peu irrationnels, ils fonctionnent comme des casseroles à pression et c'est comme s'ils avaient une limite
de résistance et qu'à partir d'un certain moment, ils vont plus tenir le coup et ils vont exploser, ils vont sortir.
Alors, moi, ce que j'ai observé par rapport à ça, je trouve que cette vision des choses, elle est pas vraiment correcte.
Je pense que la plupart des gens, ils ont été en mesure de comprendre les raisons de ce confinement, les raisons qui étaient proposées ici par les autorités, surtout-- 'fin, ça a été très clair, en tout cas,
dans, je dirais, dans le premier mois du confinement. Et,
et je veux dire, les mesures ont vraiment été très bien respectées. Et je pense que ce n'est pas juste un modèle de casserole à pression, c'est une véritable adhésion
à des normes, ici, de solidarité, une compréhension que la santé de chacun est mise en danger par le comportement de tous.
Et ce qu'on a vu, évidemment, c'est qu'y a certains groupes, certaines collectivités qui sont plus vulnérables par rapport aux conséquences du confinement et que par ailleurs, il y a eu des problèmes de,
clairement, de gestion, de communication, dans la gestion des masques, notamment, du testing, etc.
Et que ça crée une sorte de force centrifuge et qu'on a certaines poches de la population qui trouvent ça sans doute moins légitime.
Mais je pense que ce n'est pas en raison d'un modèle de casserole à pression, c'est parce que
pour ces groupes sociaux, bah, y a clairement des questions à se poser quant à la légitimité de ce genre de politique qui est proposée et du rapport coût/bénéfice, finalement, que ça représente.
Ils ont des raisons, je dirais, objectives et subjectivement rationnelles, en tout cas, de remettre en cause le confinement.
Mmh. Vous disiez, si je ne me trompe pas sur votre blog, que, voilà, cette idée, cette analogie de la casserole à pression
repose finalement sur une certaine forme de paternalisme selon laquelle l'État ne doit pas prendre les mesures les plus efficaces en raison des limites psychologiques de la population-
Ouais, oui, c'est ça
...et que la population, c'est un petit peu la variable qu'on ne contrôle pas, qui est irrationnelle, qui va tout foutre en l'air, finalement.
Voilà. Donc avec l'idée de la casserole à pression, en fait, c'est à l'État à proposer des solutions aux gens et à contrôler les gens et à les amener à prendre des bonnes décisions malgré eux.
Oui, malgré les gens, voilà.
Ouais, parce qu'ils vont jamais être capables de prendre les bonnes décisions tout seuls. Donc notamment, y a toute une approche qui est très populaire en Angleterre, qui s'appelle le nudging.
En français, ça veut dire le coup de pouce. Donc, Richard Thaler, un de ses auteurs, a reçu le prix Nobel, en partie pour ces travaux-là en économie.
Et oh ben en fait, c'est de la psychologie sociale pour moi, et qui consiste en gros à dire : « Ben on va un petit peu changer l'environnement pour faire ceci ou cela, et c'est ça qui va permet--
» Et finalement, inconsciemment, les gens vont adopter les bons comportements parce qu'on aura modifié,
à leur insu l'environnement de façon à ce qu'ils l'adoptent.
L'exemple classique de ça, même si ça n'a rien à voir avec l'épidémie, c'est de mettre un petit dessin, une mouche, au fond d'un urinoir pour être sûr que les messieurs visent bien.
Ils se rendent en fait pas compte qu'ils ont été influencés par la mouche, mais l'effet net, c'est que, ben voilà, y a moins de nettoyage à faire après.
Donc, c'est vraiment une politique ici qui n'est pas nécessairement irrationnelle ou stupide, mais qui est très paternale. C'est voilà, on va-
Ouais
...modifier votre environnement pour que vous preniez les bonnes décisions, même si vous vous rendez pas compte des raisons pour lesquelles vous les prenez, même si vous n'êtes pas nécessairement d'accord avec ces décisions.
C'est alors sans doute aussi dans l'idée de-- comme vous n'êtes pas conscient de ces changements, vous n'êtes peut-être pas en mesure de protester et d'être en colère contre le pouvoir en place.
J'imagine que c'est un facteur aussi.
Oui, tout à fait. Alors c'est une approche qui peut être utilisée, mais qui ne suffit pas quoi. Donc, je veux dire, en Belgique, on a aussi un peu utilisé ça.
J'sais pas, enfin, par exemple, si on met des distributeurs de gel hydroalcoolique, c'est aussi un peu du nudging, hein, ça, d'en mettre un peu partout, ça pousse les gens à en mettre, mais ça ne suffit clairement pas.
Et c'est très important que les gens adhèrent aux politiques pour des bonnes raisons-
Mmh
...et qu'on ne se contente pas de ce genre de petits gadgets, à mon avis, hein. Ça, c'est mon avis personnel.
Et alors, mais plus précisément, la question de la distanciation physique, le fait qu'on ne puisse plus sortir voir ses amis, on ne puisse plus,
aller en société, aller à des événements, aller au cinéma, aller au restaurant et que quand on voit quelqu'un, on doit à tout prix essayer de rester à au moins 1 mètre 50.
Qu'est-ce que vous tirez comme conclusion sur base de ça ? Qu'est-ce que vous remarquez ?
Ben, je dirais que globalement, les gens ont l'air de suivre ces recommandations. Maintenant, j'ai pas fait d'études de terrain directes là-dessus.
C'est un peu compliqué d'ailleurs.
Mmh.
Mais, moi, quelque chose que je remarque, c'est peut-être une augmentation de la méfiance. Donc, l'autre devient une menace potentielle quand on se balade dans la rue.
Donc on va s'éloigner. Donc on est finalement dans un rapport qui, par défaut, est celui de la méfiance.
Alors que je dirais, généralement, notre rapport par défaut aux autres, c'est plutôt la confiance. Donc quand on va être dans le déconfinement, je pense que ça va être compliqué de finalement- ...bien
faire la différence entre la distanciation physique et la distanciation sociale.
Parce que ce qu'on nous a demandé de faire, c'est de la distanciation physique. On a au contraire besoin d'un rapprochement social par d'autres moyens.
Et donc je crains que-
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi est-ce qu'on a ce besoin ?
Ah, je pense que c'est particulièrement important. Dès lors qu'on est isolé physiquement, on va devoir trouver d'autres moyens de--
donc non seulement on est isolé physiquement, mais on est souvent, pour beaucoup de gens, aussi fragilisé,
d'autres façons, parce qu'on est confronté à de nouvelles exigences en termes de travail, en termes de vie de famille, quand on doit faire du télétravail avec en plus des enfants à la maison, par exemple.
Ou alors quand on est-- imaginez qu'on soit une personne isolée qui n'ait plus de contacts sociaux physiques.
Ben, donc, finalement, face aux stress supplémentaires qui sont associés au confinement et à la réorganisation de notre mode de vie, pour y faire face, on a besoin de relations sociales et de soutien social.
La meilleure façon de faire face au stress, c'est le soutien social. Et donc on va devoir le retrouver par des moyens indirects, non physiques, vu qu'on ne peut plus les avoir par des moyens physiques.
Et alors du coup, j'ai envie de vous poser la question : quels sont les facteurs qui peuvent influer sur, voilà, le respect des gens par rapport à ces nouvelles règles ?
Parce que voilà, y en a qui,
comme moi, par exemple, restent sagement chez eux sans,
sans enfreindre les règles, mais on a tous entendu parler de personnes qui,
qui s'en foutaient, qui vont voir des amis, on a-- bon alors, je ne sais pas à quel point c'était répandu, mais on avait beaucoup parlé de ces fameuses lockdown parties des jeunes étudiants.
Qu'est-ce qui fait qu'un individu va adhérer parfaitement alors qu'un autre-- puisque là, c'est vraiment une situation, j'ai l'impression, en tout cas, de--
un scénario parfait pour étudier à travers la psychologie sociale, puisque, voilà, on change les-
Ouais
...on change les individus, mais on garde le même environnement autour d'eux et on observe des comportements très différents.
Ben, donc, qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire par rapport à ça ? Bon, à mon avis,
un facteur qui est très important, et donc là, parfois, je m'exprime sans avoir nécessairement des données directement, donc c'est une intuition, c'est clairement que les mesures aient un sens pour l'individu
et aussi par rapport à sa vision de lui-même.
Je vous donne un exemple.
Je me souviens au début, un peu avant le confinement, moi, je voyais beaucoup de gens qui,
qui ne respectaient pas du tout la distanciation sociale avec un discours du type : « Moi, c'est pas grave si je suis malade, ça me dérange pas », et cetera.
Donc, ils se présentaient un peu comme des héros qui sont prêts à aller au combat pour faire face à la maladie.
Mais évidemment, c'est un paradigme qui est totalement absurde ici, vu que la question, ce n'est pas de ne pas soi-même tomber malade, c'est avant tout de ne pas rendre malades les autres.
Et donc, en tout cas les deux. Et donc, déjà, si on arrive à interpréter cette situation comme une situation non pas de préserver sa propre santé, ce qui est le discours de santé publique habituel.
D'habitude, on vous dit : « Ne fumez pas, ne buvez pas, ne mangez pas trop de graisse, et cetera », pour préserver votre santé à vous.
Ici, en fait, il faut arriver à voir que le sens est complètement différent. En préservant votre santé, ce n'est pas votre bien-être que vous protégez, mais celui des autres.
Donc déjà, il y a cette question du sens. Et je pense que beaucoup de gens n'avaient pas tout de suite saisi ça et que ça pouvait expliquer notamment les lockdown parties.
Je dirais qu'un autre facteur qui joue, c'est ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure, c'est le rapport entre les stresseurs et les possibilités de faire face à la situation.
Si le stress et le-- si on a l'impression de faire face à des contraintes tellement fortes qu'on peut pas tenir le coup.
Et donc, moi, j'ai vu des gens qui étaient vraiment au bord de-- 'fin, qui vivaient très mal ce lockdown, qui sont dans une situation vraiment très difficile au niveau de leur santé mentale.
Bah, à un moment, quand on n'a plus de ressources et que la seule façon pour s'en sortir, ben, c'est de sortir et de voir des gens, je pense que ça, c'est clairement quelque chose qui risque de se passer.
Alors, y a des facteurs clairement purement liés à l'environnement physique dans lequel on vit. Y avait des articles très intéressants sur le vécu des jeunes des banlieues en France
qui sont coincés dans des petits appartements, dans des tours,
et donc qui, eux, vivent le confinement comme être en cage et que ça arrange bien les policiers qu'ils soient en cage comme des animaux.
Et donc eux, ils donnent un sens totalement différent à ce confinement.
C'est intéressant parce que, en fait, en expliquant un comportement, voilà, qui serait d'enfreindre les règles, en expliquant ça par des facteurs de, voilà, de
santé mentale, des facteurs de rapport aux autorités, d'est-ce qu'on est bien informé, et cetera,
on finit par--
parce que spontanément, mon réflexe à moi, en croisant quelqu'un qui enfreindrait la règle, ce serait
d'être en colère, d'être peut-être presque un peu paternaliste et de lui expliquer que c'est vraiment très mal ce qu'il fait et de l'engueuler un petit peu.
Et en donnant toutes ces explications, finalement,
est-ce que, et ça, c'est une question peut-être plus globale par rapport à la discipline qu'est la psychologie sociale, est-ce qu'on ne supprime pas,
au bout d'un moment, la question de la faute, la question de la responsabilité de l'individu,
en donnant, voilà, tous ces facteurs de son environnement qui font que, voilà, il a réagi de telle manière ?
C'est un débat philosophique.
Oui.
Est-ce que expliquer—
Tout à fait.
...est-ce que expliquer, c'est légitimer ? Je suis pas totalement sûr. Moi, pour moi, expliquer, c'est pas la même chose que légitimer.
On est d'accord.
Maintenant, y a certains types d'explications qui enlèvent une plus grande part au libre arbitre que d'autres.
Mhm.
Donc c'est clair que si on voit l'individu comme une sorte d'automate qui est en quelque sorte
téléguidé par des facteurs contextuels et qu'il peut rien faire, que s'il est confronté à tel stimulus, il va se comporter de telle façon automatiquement, on enlève toute place à la responsabilité individuelle.
Et j'ai l'impression que si je reprends, par exemple, les conceptions des foules que je critiquais au début—
Oui.
...de l'entretien, ce sont des conceptions qui sont finalement un peu de ce type-là, qui disent : « Dans une foule, l'individu est décérébré.
Il ne fait que suivre aveuglément son leader. » C'était le genre de perspective, par exemple, que défendait Le Bon et qui est encore très, très prégnante aujourd'hui.
Si on adhère à ce genre d'approche,
c'est clair qu'on, d'une certaine façon, déresponsabilise
les individus. Moi, j'ai l'impression que l'approche que j'ai essayé de défendre dans cet entretien, qui est finalement que ce qui compte, c'est le sens
que les gens donnent à leur expérience, ce n'est pas du tout une explication qui déresponsabilise les gens.
Alors, pour continuer sur, voilà, l'analyse de cette période de confinement, on a pu observer des réactions
plutôt rapides, des mesures drastiques de la part des autorités, et de la population aussi, pour lutter contre la propagation du virus.
Qu'est-ce qui explique, puisque certains ont fait la comparaison, qu'est-ce qui explique la différence d'intensité entre l'attitude que nous avons collectivement adoptée face
au nouveau coronavirus et, à côté de ça, notre attitude, je dirais, plus mollassonne, un peu plus soft, vis-à-vis de la question du réchauffement climatique qui est aussi une urgence.
Qu'est-ce qui explique que les réactions soient aussi différentes ? Puisque voilà, je sais que certains ont fait la comparaison.
C'est une bonne question. Alors, ce qu'il faut d'abord dire, à mon avis, c'est que
c'est pas juste la réaction des individus et de la population qui compte, c'est aussi la réaction des institutions qui a été beaucoup plus puissante et beaucoup plus forte.
Et il faut savoir que ce que font les institutions, c'est une des principales sources de normes sociales.
Donc si l'institution dit : « Ceci est dangereux, il faut faire quelque chose par rapport à ceci », les gens vont avoir tendance très souvent à
finalement être influencés par cette perception des choses et que ça devienne une norme sociale.
Et donc ici, je pense que la raison est le caractère beaucoup plus immédiat
du danger et que finalement la relation entre ce qu'on pouvait faire et les effets qu'on pouvait espérer empêcher étaient beaucoup plus clairs et beaucoup plus rapides dans le temps politique que—
Mmh.
...ce que ça peut être pour le changement climatique, pour le changement climatique.
Si vous prenez des mesures pour augmenter la biodiversité ou pour diminuer la déforestation, c'est pas pendant cette législature que vous en verrez les effets.
Donc l'intérêt politique de la chose n'est pas évident du tout. Et même la visibilité du résultat n'est pas claire du tout.
D'autant plus que la visibilité du phénomène du réchauffement climatique est bien moindre par rapport, voilà, aux services de soins intensifs qui se remplissent.
Donc c'est différent à ce niveau-là aussi, je pense, ouais.
Ouais, mais ça, c'est une question intéressante parce qu'apparemment, d'après les lectures que j'ai faites, y a eu d'autres grosses épidémies, notamment à la fin des années 60,
où en fait, on n'a absolument fait aucun confinement, on n'a rien fait.
Et la société a continué à fonctionner. Donc on a—
cette visibilité de l'épidémie est aussi liée à une préoccupation particulièrement importante, peut-être aujourd'hui, pour la santé individuelle, qu'on avait peut-être moins à cette époque-là.
Donc c'est vraiment une question intéressante. Et—
En effet.
...et alors je pense que ce qui a dû jouer aussi, c'est un effet d'émulation entre les différents pays en se disant : « À partir du moment où—
Où la France entame un confinement, à ce moment-là, on est un petit peu obligé de se mettre à niveau et de ne pas avoir l'air, voilà, je dirais, laxiste par rapport à la crise, quoi, ouais.
Ouais, et puis, enfin, c'est vrai qu'y avait vraiment une sorte de— on sentait la chose arriver un peu partout.
Et donc y a un moment où tout le monde s'est fermé. Je pense que c'est vraiment une question d'échelle temporelle et de rapport,
de rapport beaucoup plus proximal entre la cause et les effets que ce que n'est le changement climatique.
En plus, ici, on dirait que— on dirait peut-être un peu de façon illusoire qu'y a une solution simple, quoi. Il suffit de séparer tout le monde—
Ce sont clairs, en tout cas, ouais.
Oui. Oui, clairs.
Alors, on va à présent s'attarder sur un autre phénomène sur lequel vous vous êtes penché et que vous étudiez, c'est la question du complotisme, de la crédulité,
entre autres choses, voilà, sur les réseaux sociaux, puisque c'est là que circulent le plus
les théories complotistes.
Je me suis mis à la recherche d'informations, de recouper les informations, d'aller chercher les informations dans les sites officiels, dans les statistiques officielles.
Et plus j'ai creusé,
plus j'ai acquis la conviction que nous étions effectivement dans un immense mensonge, y compris par rapport au nombre de cas, y compris par rapport au nombre de morts, y compris par rapport à la surcharge des hôpitaux, y compris par rapport
au fait qu'il n'existe pas de remède pour guérir les personnes atteintes du coronavirus, y compris sur un tas de choses.
Je n'ai trouvé quasiment aucune vérité. Ce que j'ai trouvé, c'est une manipulation monumentale à l'échelle de la planète, avec un agenda caché, avec un agenda qui consiste à vouloir installer une dictature mondiale.
On va l'appeler comme ça. Personnellement, quand j'entends ce genre de choses, je suis assez partagé entre, d'une part, un sentiment d'amusement, puisque les allégations de ce monsieur sont assez grotesques, hein.
Il parle— plus loin dans la vidéo, il parle d'un futur vaccin qui contient des micro-puces, des euthanasies de masse, des manipulations de l'opinion publique par des puissances secrètes, mais aussi,
un sentiment de malaise profond puisque cette vidéo, avant d'être supprimée par YouTube,
avait tout de même atteint près d'un million de vues.
Donc parmi les sujets sur lesquels vous travaillez, je le disais, il y a la question de la crédulité.
Aux yeux de la science, qu'est-ce qui provoque ce complotisme et la circulation presque virale, hein, c'est comme ça qu'on dit, sans mauvais jeu de mots, la circulation virale de ces contenus sur Internet ?
Y a de nouveau plein d'explications possibles, hein, selon qu'on prenne des explications individuelles ou collectives, etc.
Mais pour répondre à votre question, je vais prendre la situation actuelle du confinement. On est dans une situation où on a toute une série de gens qui sont nécessairement
isolés chez eux, qui sont dans des situations de vulnérabilité diverses qu'on a déjà évoquées.
Et donc, clairement, ça crée de l'anxiété, de l'incertitude, etc. On est confronté par ailleurs à un discours du gouvernement qui est aussi plein d'incertitudes.
On ne sait pas très bien comment cette épidémie va évoluer. Y a évidemment aussi des erreurs dans la gestion de l'épidémie et
on peut se demander dans quelle mesure ces erreurs sont purement des erreurs ou s'il y aurait des intentions cachées derrière.
Donc, on est dans une espèce de magma, un peu, d'incertitude. Et ce que nous propose ce genre de personnage, c'est une explication qui a l'air d'une simplicité absolument proverbiale.
En fait, tout ça est un complot visant à nous enfermer dans un état totalitaire
et notamment, un des moyens que va utiliser cet état totalitaire, c'est de nous forcer à nous faire vacciner des puces qui vont nous surveiller grâce à la 5G, etc.
Donc on a vraiment une explication très très simple qui, alors d'une part, satisfait notre inconfort par rapport à l'incertitude, ça, c'est le premier élément.
Donc déjà, on se sent plus intelligent, on sait quelque chose et donc on se sent plus intelligent et plus pris comme une sorte d'imbécile qui doit rester à la maison passif.
Donc c'est valorisant. Deuxième élément, qu'on a aussi un sentiment peut-être de plus de contrôle. Dès lors qu'on sait quelle est la cause du problème, on a peut-être des réponses comportementales pour y faire face.
Par exemple, refuser de se faire vacciner s'il y a un vaccin qui est proposé. Mais aussi, il nous propose de sortir dans la rue, de défier le confinement, de nous retrouver.
Et donc on nous propose un moyen d'action positive. On n'est plus des agents passifs, on est des agents actifs. Donc ça, c'est beaucoup plus valorisant aussi.
Et on a l'impression de pouvoir répondre finalement à ce malaise grâce à ça. Et troisième élément qui me semble très important, c'est qu'il nous offre une communauté d'appartenance.
C'est-à-dire que ces millions de gens, ce ne sont pas tous des gens isolés. 'Fin, en tout cas, y a peut-être pas un million de gens, mais en tout cas, parmi tous les gens qui ont regardé ces vidéos,
ce sont des gens qui en partie font partie
de communautés, notamment sur les réseaux sociaux,
et qui échangent, qui se retrouvent et qui trouvent du lien social par rapport à ça.
Or, on a justement besoin de lien social, c'est ce que je disais précédemment. Donc il nous offre ces trois choses : une explication relativement simple, la possibilité d'agir, la possibilité d'avoir des relations sociales.
Et enfin, troisième chose, il est extrêmement facile de partager ces vidéos. On peut— si je partage cette vidéo à ma tante, je vais lui révéler ce qu'elle ignorait.
Je vais l'éclairer sur la vérité qui m'a été communiquée. Donc je fais une bonne action. Je lui révèle qu'en fait tout ce qu'elle pensait était faux et je lui donne la clé de son malaise à elle. Donc—
C'est plutôt valorisant, ouais.
...donc non seulement mon intelligence est valorisée, mais aussi mon altruisme, mon—
Ouais.
...ma vertu est valorisée. Donc c'est un cocktail merveilleux, hein. Ça explique, à mon avis, le succès de ce genre de vidéos.
Mais alors, donc la période d'incertitude que nous connaissons actuellement, elle nous affecte tous.
La séduction d'être, voilà, le— si vous me proposez, moi, de me sentir valorisé pour mon intelligence ou pour mon sens des valeurs morales, etc.,
je ne dis pas non.
Mais voilà, vous et moi, nous avons vu cette vidéo de ce complotiste. Nous ne sommes pas convaincus par cette théorie, mais visiblement, d'autres y croient dur comme fer.
Alors, je pose du coup la question : est-ce que nous sommes tous égaux face à ce genre de contenu ?
Non, on n'est pas tous égaux, mais de quoi ça dépend ? Alors, y a des chercheurs qui ont étudié, par exemple, l'effet des compétences cognitives type QI, même des variations sur ce sujet-là.
Et c'est vrai qu'il y a une petite corrélation, c'est-à-dire des gens qui scorent, qui sont moins capables de réfléchir logiquement, ont un peu plus tendance à croire au complotisme.
Le niveau d'éducation joue aussi, mais à mon avis de façon aussi assez faible en fait. Mais ce qui, à mon avis, joue avant tout, à nouveau, ce sont des facteurs sociaux. C'est-à-dire que, en fait, on—
ce que dit— alors, ça, j'aime bien cette expression parce qu'elle est, bon, elle est un peu caricaturale, mais un spécialiste américain des théories du complot, il dit : « Conspiracy theories are for losers ».
Les théories du complot, c'est pour les perdants.
Mhm.
Et en fait—
Mhm, mhm.
...et en fait, ce qu'on constate, c'est que l'adhésion aux théories du complot, c'est quelque chose qu'on va retrouver beaucoup plus chez des gens qui se sentent appartenir à des groupes qui sont dévalorisés.
Ouais, donc c'est losers non pas au sens péjoratif ou méprisant, mais vraiment quand on parle des dominés, quoi, dans une— ouais.
Que vous, vous n'y croyez pas ou que moi, je me dise : « Qu'est-ce que c'est que cet illuminé
? » Ça vient du fait que, en fait, on a un réseau social et on a une série de sources d'information en lesquelles on a confiance
et qui finalement ne rendent pas nécessaire, et on a sans doute aussi une certaine sécurité psychologique qui ne rend pas nécessaire d'adhérer à ce genre de discours, mais...
Mh, mh, mh. Y avait effectivement, en tout cas, c'est ce qu'on a pu lire et c'est ce que j'ai pu observer directement, y avait beaucoup de complotisme, par exemple chez les Gilets jaunes en France.
Donc voilà, on parlait des losers, donc voilà, les strates les plus fragilisées de la société.
En dessous, dans les commentaires de la vidéo de ce complotiste, il y avait justement des personnes qui se revendiquaient du mouvement des Gilets jaunes.
Donc ça confirme très fort ce que vous disiez, oui.
Ah oui, parce que en fait, ils remettent en cause les élites, en fait. Hein, c'est le cœur de ce type de complotisme, c'est que c'est les élites qui complotent.
Et donc le mouvement des Gilets jaunes, c'est un mouvement
clairement qui va à l'encontre des élites. Et donc— alors, tous les Gilets jaunes ne sont pas complotistes, mais c'est clair qu'il y a des affinités très, très naturelles entre le complotisme et le mouvement des Gilets jaunes.
Y a effectivement un aspect qui m'a semblé très récurrent. C'est, vous disiez, ce rapport aux puissants qui nous manipulent secrètement, qui nous trompent et contre lesquels il faut se rebeller.
Et alors, le moyen que nous propose ce complotiste, c'est : vous pouvez vous rebeller facilement, vous partagez la vidéo.
Et c'est un moyen de lever le poing au ciel pour, voilà, regagner un certain contrôle de la situation, ouais.
Voilà, exactement.
Parce que je demandais donc ce qui faisait que nous ne sommes pas tous égaux par rapport à ce genre de contenu. Là, vous proposiez un aspect qui est le statut social.
Est-ce qu'on est plutôt aisé ou plutôt fragilisé dans cette société ? Vous parliez également de la question du QI, de l'éducation.
Est-ce qu'il y a encore d'autres aspects dont on pourrait parler ?
Ça peut aussi être lié. Alors, y a aussi toute une partie de la littérature maintenant qui s'intéresse à ce qu'on appelle le narcissisme collectif.
D'accord.
Et donc c'est cette idée en gros que— 'fin, c'est une forme de patriotisme aveugle par rapport à son propre groupe.
Et donc ça a notamment été étudié très fort en Pologne par des chercheurs d'origine polonaise, des chercheuses d'origine polonaise.
Et donc là aussi, on voit vraiment un lien assez fort entre une espèce d'attachement aveugle et très marqué à son propre groupe et l'idée alors que son groupe ne peut jamais rien faire de mal.
Et donc le complotisme. Et donc, par exemple, pour prendre l'exemple de la Pologne, l'idée que c'est nécessairement les Russes qui ont abattu l'avion du président polonais qui est tombé y a quelques années.
Ah oui, oui.
Ça, c'est aussi— donc finalement, est-il complotiste ? C'est une façon de préserver l'image de son groupe
plutôt que de devoir accepter qu'on a fait certaines bêtises, on va rejeter ça sur un groupe extérieur qu'on va rendre responsable de ça.
C'est un peu ce que Trump est en train de faire en accusant les Chinois d'être— ou les Européens, d'être à l'origine de l'épidémie.
Donc ça, c'est aussi un facteur, c'est quand on est très fort attaché à son groupe et qu'il est potentiellement responsable
du malheur auquel on fait face, bah on va souvent essayer de résoudre ce problème psychologique qu'on peut vivre en rejetant la responsabilité sur un autre groupe.
Et le complotisme, c'est souvent ça, c'est—
Mmh.
...attribuer à un autre groupe qu'on déteste des desseins dangereux ou pervers qui expliquent alors la situation dans laquelle nous nous trouvons.
Ouais, donc on resserre les liens entre nous et finalement, on rejette la faute sur l'autre, sur—
Voilà.
...les autres. Et ce sera souvent alors les personnes différentes, d'autres groupes ethniques, d'autres—
Voilà, c'est une fonction de consolidation, en fait. Le complotisme, ça permet de consolider l'identité du groupe vu qu'on le rejette, vu qu'on désigne un exogroupe comme responsable.
Donc c'est comme ça que marchent beaucoup de discours politiques, en créant un épouvantail à l'extérieur pour resserrer les liens au sein du groupe.
Oui.
Alors, je sais que vous avez également supervisé il y a quelques années un— il me semble que c'était un doctorat qui soutenait l'idée que les personnes
qui croient— 'fin, voilà, de nouveau une corrélation entre les personnes qui ont tendance à
croire aux thèses complotistes et chez ces personnes, un certain—
puisque vous évoquiez la question du narcissisme
collectif, mais dans ce cas-ci, plutôt à l'échelle individuelle,
un certain besoin d'unicité,
Le fait de dire, si j'ai bien compris, le fait de dire : « J'ai une explication que personne d'autre a.
Je suis le seul à avoir compris ou un des rares à avoir compris la vérité de ce qui est en train de se passer. Et donc je suis un peu spécial. » Et donc ça, j'estime que c'est un petit peu valorisant.
Oui, tout à fait. Ça, c'est des travaux dans lesquels je ne suis pas directement impliqué, mais j'étais notamment dans le jury de thèse d'Anthony Lantian qui a-
Mmh
...qui a travaillé là-dessus à l'université de Grenoble. Et donc effectivement, ce que lui montrait, c'est qu'il y avait vraiment un lien entre ce qu'il appelle le besoin d'unicité et l'adhésion aux théories du complot.
Donc le besoin de se sentir différent et distinct des autres. Et effectivement, des gens comme ça, ils vous donnent le sentiment que vous accédez, grâce à eux, à une vérité à laquelle les autres n'ont pas accès.
Donc, vous êtes moins naïf que les autres, vous êtes plus-
Mmh
...vous êtes plus clairvoyant. Et donc-
On passe finalement du statut du vulgum pecus au statut de presque un héros quoi. On est-
Ouais, ouais
...on est en train de lutter pour la libération de ce peuple confiné, enfermé, oppressé, voilà, ouais.
Ouais, donc ouais, on est différent des autres. D'ailleurs, c'est assez intéressant quand des gens qui adhèrent aux théories du complot font des commentaires
soit sur mes billets, soit sur Internet, on voit souvent qu'ils parlent des autres comme des moutons.
Les autres sont des moutons et eux, ils sont pas des moutons, ils sont des gens différents qui ont accès à la vérité.
Et donc ça, c'est très important et c'est un des attraits de ce genre de théorie, c'est que, quand je disais que les gens ont besoin de se sentir, 'fin, que ça donne l'impression d'être intelligent,
c'est un peu la même idée. On se sent plus-
Ouais
...intelligent, plus malin que les autres quoi.
Et ce besoin d'unicité, est-ce que, voilà, à travers le prisme de la psychologie sociale, d'où ça vient ?
Est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui nous concerne tous ? Est-ce qu'on a tous un petit peu ce besoin de se sentir spéciaux, uniques ?
Ça, c'est quelque chose qui est très particulier, qui est très spécifique à des cultures individualistes comme la nôtre, mais-
Mmh-mmh
...donc par exemple, y a une étude, moi, que j'adore raconter à mes étudiants, qui est une étude qui a été faite en même temps aux États-Unis et dans un pays asiatique.
C'est une étude de Kim et Markus. Et ce qu'ils ont fait, c'est qu'ils ont été dans des halls d'aéroport en demandant aux gens de remplir un questionnaire.
Et en fait, ils se moquaient totalement des réponses au questionnaire. Ce qui les intéressait, c'était quel stylo les gens allaient choisir.
Y avait toujours quatre stylos, en tout cas dans une des conditions expérimentales, y avait quatre stylos rouges et un vert.
Et on faisait ça dans les deux pays. Et ce qu'on constatait, c'est que les Américains, ils choisissaient toujours le stylo de couleur minoritaire.
Donc s'il y avait quatre rouges et un vert, ils choisissaient le vert, en tout cas très souvent. Alors que les Asiatiques, ils choisissaient de façon majoritaire un des stylos de la couleur majoritaire.
Donc s'il y avait quatre rouges et un vert, ils allaient plutôt choisir un rouge. Et bon, bien sûr, on-
Pour en quelque sorte passer inaperçu, ouais
Oui, donc c'est en fait pour montrer qu'ils sont comme les autres, qu'ils sont intégrés dans le groupe.
C'est une façon de voir les choses. Alors que l'Américain veut se distinguer, il veut montrer qu'il n'est pas comme les autres.
Et donc ce besoin d'unicité, il est particulièrement marqué dans des cultures individualistes.
Pas de complotisme au Japon alors ?
Non, non, y a bien sûr du complotisme au Japon, en Afrique aussi. Moi, j'entends les théories du complot sur le COVID en Afrique.
Y a des théories selon lesquelles, en fait, le but, c'est de se débarrasser des Noirs, etc., vu que ça touche plus les Noirs aux États-Unis, par exemple.
Et donc, clairement, y a une-
y a aussi des théories, enfin, c'est pas la seule explication, c'est pas le besoin d'unicité, c'est ce que j'ai essayé de dire, mais
ce facteur-là est particulièrement important dans des pays occidentaux de culture individualiste comme le nôtre ou comme les États-Unis.
Ouais, c'est très intéressant. Donc y a visiblement tout un ensemble de facteurs qui peuvent nous affecter tous plus ou moins.
On sait que les fake news, qui sont, voilà, très, très alarmantes, qui nous confortent dans nos opinions, voilà, et qui donc englobent également, voilà, les contenus complotistes dont nous parlions.
On sait que les fake news circulent bien plus rapidement sur les réseaux sociaux que les informations vérifiées.
Alors, je pose la question : comment fait-on pour freiner la diffusion de ces théories du complot, voilà, comme l'exemple qu'on a entendu tout à l'heure ?
Alors, ça, c'est vraiment une question, si on avait la réponse-
Question à un million, oui.
Oui, donc la première question, c'est tout d'abord, les théories du complot, elles sont pas toujours fausses.
Parfois, y a des vrais complots. Donc, y a vraiment une question d'abord de liberté d'expression. Il faut pas empêcher les véritables complots d'être découverts et d'être révélés.
Donc c'est vraiment une-
La censure n'est pas une réponse, ouais
Bon, en tout cas, une censure générale sur tout discours complotiste serait-
C'est ça
...tout à fait contraire à-
Voilà
...aux principes qui organisent notre État de droit. Donc, comment les freiner ? Ben,
une des solutions qui a été fort utilisée, c'est le fact-checking, qui consistait à reprendre toute une série d'informations sur des sites ou sur des journaux,
qui reprenaient toutes les informations et mentionnaient si elles étaient fausses ou vraies.
Et je pense que ça a un effet chez une certaine catégorie de la population qui va effectivement corriger certaines croyances sur base de ça.
Mais clairement, ça ne suffit pas. Par exemple, en ce qui concerne Trump, le Washington Post reprend toutes les allégations qu'il fait et le taux de mensonges reste très élevé.
Ça n'a absolument pas entamé sa popularité. C'est en tout cas pas ça qui a entamé sa popularité. Donc ça ne suffit pas.
Et en ce qui concerne les théories complotistes, comme par exemple, voilà, celle de la personne qu'on a entendue tout à l'heure, je pense que justement,
le fait d'avoir les pouvoirs en place, les institutions, soit supprimer la vidéo, soit préciser que les contenus sont absolument fantaisistes,
ça ne fait que les conforter, en tout cas, j'ai l'impression, dans ce sentiment d'oppression, de : « Les puissants essayent de nous cacher la vérité.
Regardez, ils réduisent ma capacité d'être entendu. »
Donc ça, c'est effectivement quelque chose que, par exemple, ce personnage-là utilise. C'est qu'il dit : « Les médias ont toujours essayé de me bâillonner.
» Donc le fait que sa vidéo soit retirée sur YouTube, par exemple, peut être interprété de nouveau comme une manipulation des puissants pour l'empêcher de s'exprimer.
Donc qu'on le laisse parler ou qu'on le laisse pas parler, finalement, il peut dans les deux cas utiliser ça pour faire avancer son message.
Mais donc, pour répondre à votre question, on peut faire des interventions au niveau individuel, psychologique, qui marchent pas trop mal.
Je vais vous donner un exemple. C'est par exemple, j'ai vu une étude sur le fait de s'affirmer en se disant que finalement, croire aux théories du complot, c'est-
ça manifeste une certaine forme d'incertitude, de sécurité, souvent d'un sentiment de vulnérabilité par rapport à ses connaissances, à ses croyances, voire à ce qu'on pense et
la façon dont on apprend le monde.
Et donc, si on valorisait les gens, si on leur donnait une occasion de se valoriser, peut-être qu'ils auraient moins besoin de croire à certaines de ces choses-là.
Et donc, par exemple, y a une expérience
dont je me souviens plus exactement les détails, mais qui utilisait ça comme manipulation et ça avait un effet sur l'adhésion, ici, à des complots, je pense, qui portaient sur la vaccination.
Donc quand les gens avaient l'occasion de s'affirmer préalablement, ben ils y croyaient moins. Donc ça, c'est le genre d'intervention qu'on peut faire au niveau individuel.
Maintenant, est-ce qu'on peut demander au gouvernement de lancer ce genre d'initiative ? Ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens, au niveau général.
Et donc, je pense que ce qui est important quand on veut faire au niveau général, c'est avant tout qu'il y ait un accès à l'information correcte et une éducation qui permette d'apprendre à distinguer certaines sources,
mais aussi une forme de, ce qu'on appelle
une forme d'éducation aux médias.
Il faut savoir que la plupart, enfin souvent, les théories complotistes, elles cachent des agendas financiers.
Si on prend l'individu dont on a entendu la vidéo tout à l'heure, il propose en effet qu'on rejoigne son site privé sur lequel on peut acheter une série de formations payantes.
Voilà, ben donc souvent, les théories du complot sont aussi diffusées par des sites qui sont payés à ce qu'on appelle en anglais le clickbait, c'est-à-dire que
le simple fait qu'on aille sur leur site augmente les revenus publicitaires.
Et c'est clair que la véracité des informations n'a aucun intérêt pour eux. Donc, je pense qu'une forme d'éducation à la source des informations, aller voir
pour quelle raison cette personne communique, c'est aussi une façon d'aborder le problème.
Mais c'est une question qui est beaucoup plus, c'est un travail de fond et donc c'est pas évident à faire du tout.
Donc il faut vraiment former les gens déjà à la psychologie, je dirais cognitive, à la psychologie sociale, aux médias eux-mêmes.
Et donc quand je dis former les gens, c'est former les gens qui vont enseigner aux enfants à faire ça. Et donc c'est vraiment pas évident du tout.
Donc d'une part, si j'ai bien compris, une forme d'éducation aux médias, et ça, vous n'êtes pas le premier invité à exiger que ce soit bien plus présent dans le programme d'enseignement.
Et d'autre part, peut-être aussi répondre de manière plus directe au malaise que ressentent de base ces personnes et pour lequel cette solution rapide vient proposer, voilà, une échappatoire.
Ce que j'ai dit, je pense finalement le message que j'ai essayé de communiquer, c'est que souvent, l'adhésion au complot, c'est en fait une-
ça reflète plus fondamentalement une méfiance par rapport aux politiques, à la façon dont s'organise la politique dans la société.
C'est : je n'ai plus confiance dans les élites, dans les gens qui sont censés me représenter. Je les vois comme des élites plutôt que comme des gens qui me représentent.
Ouais, ouais.
Et donc j'ai l'impression qu'une solution de fond ne peut passer que par une-
Un regain de confiance ?
Oui, et une réflexion plus approfondie sur comment faire de la politique aujourd'hui pour que les gens se sentent représentés.
Et moi j'ai pas évidemment une bonne solution pour ça, mais c'est ça pour moi le défi principal.
J'avais en effet pu lire que, de nouveau, quand on faisait des études à grande échelle,
les personnes qui sont les plus susceptibles de croire aux théories du complot sont aussi des gens qui ont tendance, par exemple, à ne pas aller voter parce que-
Oui
...ils ont très peu confiance en nos politiciens. Et donc finalement, voilà, si je pose la question, si je suis vraiment de mauvaise foi et que je pose la question : « Bah
finalement, les personnes qui croient à ces théories du complot, tant pis pour eux, non ? »
Si vous écoutez les complotistes, ce que ces personnes proposent notamment, c'est des actions violentes contre la police et des choses comme ça. Donc-
Oui, et d'enflammer les tours 5G, ce genre de choses, voilà, ouais.
Mais donc oui, ben donc, j'veux dire,
en fait, plus on vous présente un ennemi dangereux et maléfique, ce qu'ils font, ils nous disent qu'en fait tout ça, ce sont des agents totalitaires,
tout à fait, qui sont prêts à tout pour nous dominer et nous faire du tort, etc.
Plus des actions violentes et dangereuses à l'encontre de ceux qui sont supposés représenter ces ennemis sont probables.
Donc les complotistes sont potentiellement un danger pour la société, pour le bien-être physique et mental des gens qui les entourent.
Et donc y a eu plusieurs cas de tueries et d'actes violents de la part de complotistes. Par exemple, aux États-Unis, y avait ce complot complètement délirant selon lequel Clinton organisait-
Ouais, le pizzagate
...voilà, organisait un réseau pédophile depuis une pizzeria. Y a un type qui a été avec son fusil dans la pizzeria.
Donc y a vraiment un danger-
Ouais
...c'est pas juste eux qu'ils mettent en danger, c'est aussi souvent d'autres personnes.
Tout à fait. Voilà, donc je posais cette question en étant vraiment de mauvaise foi, mais voilà, vous avez très bien répondu.
On approche tout doucement de la fin de cette interview. On le disait en début de podcast, vous donnez donc un cours de psychologie de genre à l'ULB.
Alors, j'ai envie de poser la question tout simplement : qu'est-ce que c'est, ce cours de psychologie de genre et qui le suit ?
Alors, la psychologie du genre, c'est en fait... Alors d'abord, je dirais que c'est plus un cours de psychologie sociale du genre, parce que ma discipline, c'est la psychologie sociale.
Mh.
Et donc le genre, c'est quelque chose qui est lié à la culture, à nos appartenances sociales, la façon dont on définit ce qu'est être une femme, ce qu'est être un homme, éventuellement quels sont les autres genres.
Ce sont des questions qui relèvent de normes sociales aussi. Et donc
finalement, moi j'étudie avec les étudiants la façon dont ces normes sociales influencent nos comportements, notre rapport aux autres, et même les inégalités sociales entre hommes et femmes notamment.
Et c'est un cours qui est donné à des étudiants de troisième année en psychologie et en sciences de l'éducation ainsi qu'en logopédie.
Et c'est aussi donné à des étudiants qui suivent le master Genre interuniversitaire entre l'ULB et l'UCLouvain.
Très bien. Donc voilà, donc il s'agit, si je comprends bien, vraiment d'étudier tout ce qui concerne les, voilà, les rôles genrés, le,
ce qu'on attend en termes d'apparence, ce qu'on attend en termes, voilà, j'allais vous demander, puisque j'ai cru voir en lisant votre blog qu'il y avait parfois un malentendu en ce qui concerne la définition du mot sexisme,
que parfois c'était compris dans un sens et parfois dans un autre.
Alors, je vous pose la question de manière très simple : qu'est-ce que c'est le sexisme ?
Bah oui, donc y a plein de définitions. Donc la définition, je dirais standard en psychologie sociale, c'est juste de dire que le sexisme, c'est une attitude négative vis-à-vis d'un membre de l'autre sexe. D'accord ? Et donc-
Ouais
...ou même vis-à-vis des membres d'un groupe en raison de leur sexe. Et donc, le problème de cette définition,
surtout par rapport au sexisme, c'est qu'en fait, y a toute une série d'attitudes que les hommes notamment peuvent avoir vis-à-vis des femmes qui, d'apparence, sont extrêmement flatteuses, positives.
Donc tout ce qui relève par exemple de la galanterie, de l'esprit un peu chevaleresque qui consisterait à aller d'abord sauver les femmes avant de sauver les hommes, d'aider les femmes avant de sauver les hommes.
Donc toutes ces choses-là, en fait, relèvent aussi d'une forme de sexisme selon plusieurs auteurs, parce que ce faisant, ces comportements contribuent à
renforcer, à valoriser les femmes qui se conforment à leur rôle de genre, donc aux rôles sociaux qui sont attendus étant donné qu'elles sont des femmes.
Et donc, voir le sexisme juste comme une attitude négative vis-à-vis des femmes ou comme une forme de mépris ou de haine des femmes, c'est tout à fait réducteur.
Pour comprendre la façon dont les attitudes vis-à-vis des femmes influencent les relations sociales et les inégalités sociales qui existent entre hommes et femmes, il faut aussi prendre en compte ces comportements d'apparence positive.
Si on part du constat que ce mot « sexisme » peut être compris de bien des manières différentes, est-ce que ce n'est pas un mot
qu'il faudrait éviter et essayer d'employer des mots peut-être qui présentent un risque plus faible d'ambiguïté, de malentendu ?
Je ne sais pas. Puisque vous donnez l'exemple sur votre blog d'une de vos étudiantes qui n'avait visiblement pas la même définition que vous.
Oui, bah, pff, je pense que c'est assez normal dans le sens commun et dans le langage commun,
de ne pas définir les termes de façon aussi précise et aussi différenciée que ce qu'on va le faire dans le cadre d'un cours.
Donc, je pense juste que comme j'ai essayé de le faire dans le blog, il faut essayer de, quand quelqu'un vous accuse de sexisme, il faut essayer de comprendre ce qu'il entend par là.
Et souvent, en discutant, on finit par bien se comprendre.
Ouais, ouais, je suis d'accord avec ça, ouais.
La plupart des gens ne considéreront pas la galanterie comme du sexisme. Et donc,
pour comprendre pourquoi et dans quel cas la galanterie peut relever du sexisme, il faut faire déjà une analyse qui dépasse sans doute ce que la plupart des gens font spontanément.
Oui, c'est vrai.
Et donc dans ma discussion avec l'étudiante, je pense que la question, c'était : est-ce qu'il y a du sexisme à l'égard des hommes ?
Et donc elle disait : « Ben oui, vous n'arrêtez pas de nous parler du sexisme à l'égard des femmes, mais qu'en est-il du sexisme à l'égard des hommes ?
» Et cette question demandait vraiment ici de définir ce qu'on entendait par sexisme. Et donc, en l'occurrence,
pour moi, l'idée d'un sexisme à l'égard des hommes, si on le définit comme des attitudes purement négatives, mais qui ont un effet aussi
négatif sur la possibilité des hommes de s'élever socialement, d'accéder à certains rôles sociaux, il est relativement limité par rapport à ce que subissent les femmes.
Donc c'est ça que j'essayais de—
Mmh mmh.
...de voir avec elle quoi.
Et alors, je pose la question : si on s'intéresse au sexisme, si on s'intéresse aux questions des genres à travers le prisme de la psychologie sociale,
en cette période de crise sanitaire, est-ce qu'on observe des phénomènes liés au sexisme et aux traitements discriminatoires sur base du genre ?
En tout cas, on a des enjeux qui clairement relèvent du sexisme. Donc, pour vous donner un exemple, y avait une photo assez récemment de toute l'équipe de conseillers de Macron,
et on présentait ça un peu comme ça, comme le,
le QG de la lutte contre le coronavirus avec les têtes les plus affûtées pour y faire face.
Et on voyait qu'y avait, je pense, uniquement des hommes ou peut-être une femme cachée dans les 20 personnes autour de la table.
Et donc, c'est d'autant plus paradoxal que,
'fin parmi les victimes du coronavirus et les— mais aussi parmi, surtout parmi les gens qui s'occupent de ces victimes, bah, y a surtout des femmes.
Donc parmi le personnel soignant, quand même beaucoup plus d'infirmières que d'infirmiers. Idem dans les maisons de repos, où beaucoup plus de personnel féminin que de personnel masculin.
Alors, en tout ce qui concerne les patients, je ne sais pas, mais vu la longévité plus importante des femmes, j'imagine aussi que parmi les victimes, il doit y avoir, en tout cas chez les personnes âgées, très âgées, plus de femmes que d'hommes.
Mais ça, je n'en ai pas la certitude. Et donc ça, c'est de ce côté-là, mais aussi pour gérer les conséquences du confinement, où on va se retrouver à devoir faire du télétravail et à s'occuper des enfants en même temps.
Bah, y a fort à parier que le poids soit plus dur à porter pour les femmes, surtout les femmes seules, parce qu'y a beaucoup plus de parents isolés parmi les femmes que parmi les hommes.
Et donc ils vont, qui vont devoir se retrouver à combiner le travail et le soin à leurs enfants. Donc en termes de contraintes pesant sur les femmes par rapport aux hommes, c'est clair que y a une inégalité très claire.
Et donc toute la question en tant que psychologue du genre, c'est : dans quelle mesure est-ce que, 'fin, finalement, ce confinement est perçu comme aussi un problème de genre.
Est-ce qu'on voit cette épidémie à travers le prisme du genre ? Et j'pense qu'y a très peu de gens qui le voient comme ça.
Finalement, on se dit : « C'est un problème avant tout de santé publique. » Et j'trouve que ça pose des questions très intéressantes.
Une autre question que ça pose au niveau du genre, c'est la question du leadership, où on a pour la première fois une première ministre plutôt qu'un premier ministre.
Et donc elle nous donne l'image de ce que ça peut être une femme qui dirige la Belgique. Et très souvent, ça a été une expérience très très dangereuse pour des femmes d'être amenées à—
en tout cas pour la cause des femmes, ça a été difficile parce que comme c'est la première femme à diriger la Belgique, y a un risque que finalement son action soit vue comme emblématique de ce qu'est une femme dirigeante.
Alors qu'on va jamais dire après le gouvernement Michel : « Voilà ce que fait un homme quand il dirige la Belgique.
» Elle a aussi, d'une certaine façon, une pression, j'ai l'impression, qui joue soit consciemment, soit inconsciemment sur elle, qui est de montrer ce que ça peut être une femme qui dirige la Belgique.
Et alors, on a ce couple assez, presque amusant entre Maggie De Block et Sophie Wilmès. Finalement deux femmes très très différentes qui sont aux commandes les plus importantes de cette épidémie.
Donc j'trouve que y a— alors, tout ça sont plutôt des questions qui, en termes de psychologie du genre, qui s'ouvrent.
Comment est-ce qu'on va percevoir une leader femme ? Plutôt que des réponses. J'ai pas fait d'études encore là-dessus, mais j'trouve qu'y a plein d'enjeux intéressants qui se posent ici.
Très bien, mais c'est fantastique.
Pour se quitter, je vous propose une question toute simple. Si vous deviez rectifier une idée reçue que beaucoup de gens peuvent avoir au sujet de
la psychologie, de la société, de la façon dont les gens se comportent, et que, voilà, vous qui êtes professeur, vous qui étudiez ces questions, vous êtes
en mesure de rectifier.
Est-ce que vous avez en tête ? Une idée reçue, quelque chose sur lequel beaucoup de gens se trompent ?
Bah une idée reçue qui est très pertinente par rapport à la période que nous vivons, c'est l'idée que le comportement et les idées, elles se transmettent comme les virus, elles sont contagieuses.
Et donc on a souvent cette idée qu'y a une sorte d'épidémie des idées, des croyances, etc. Quand on dit que les gens sont des moutons, par exemple, c'est comme si
tout le monde suivait de façon totalement irréfléchie
ce que son voisin a fait, un peu comme s'il était infecté par le virus de son comportement.
Et ça, c'est vraiment une idée reçue. L'influence sociale, ça n'a rien à voir avec la contagion. C'est pas du tout la même chose.
L'influence sociale, ça repose sur la façon dont on perçoit la personne qui nous influence. Et donc on ne va pas être influencé de la même façon par n'importe qui, parce que ça dépendra de la
de la façon dont on perçoit cette personne, son message, ce qu'elle veut faire, etc. Et donc—
Mh.
...de nouveau, il faut, 'fin les gens sont beaucoup moins irrationnels qu'on ne le pense.
Ouais. Et la façon dont je percevrai mon interlocuteur dépend elle-même d'une série de facteurs environnementaux.
Oui, tout à fait, bien sûr. Ouais, ouais.
Très bien. Merci beaucoup, Olivier Klein, pour ces—
Avec grand plaisir, merci à vous
...un peu plus que 70 minutes passées avec moi. Et à dans deux semaines pour le prochain épisode. Au revoir.
Au revoir.
Voilà, c'est déjà tout pour cet épisode. J'étais ravi de pouvoir m'entretenir une heure avec Olivier Klein, qui tombait vraiment à point nommé.
La bonne nouvelle, c'est que si ça vous a intéressé, le Centre de recherche en psychologie sociale et interculturelle de l'ULB produit son propre podcast.
Ça s'appelle « Milligrammes de savoir » et ils reçoivent régulièrement des chercheurs en psychologie sociale pour aborder en profondeur des questions comme
l'objectification sexuelle, la mémoire collective, la soumission à l'autorité, la nature contre culture, etc.
Je l'ai écouté pour préparer cette émission. Olivier Klein y apparaît parfois et franchement, je recommande. Pour ceux que le sujet intéresse très fort, Olivier Klein a récemment publié un manuel de psychologie sociale avec Vincent Yzerbyt.
C'est abordable par tous et c'est publié chez De Boeck.
J'ai mis tous les liens dans la description. Si cet épisode vous a plu, n'oubliez pas de suivre Septante Minutes Avec sur les réseaux sociaux et de vous abonner au podcast pour ne pas manquer les suivants. À très vite.